hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar can definitive drug screening
become routine challenges and solutions
i'm susie valdez of lab roots and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by waters corporation
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
may have during this presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we will
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation you
may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
now this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credit
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain those credits i'd now like to
welcome our speaker dr thomas rosano a
toxicologist and director at the
national toxicology center and professor
emeritus at the albany medical college
dr asano welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
oh it's a
pleasure to participate in this webinar
session and have an opportunity to share
with you our experience
in the conversion to a direct to
definitive drug testing program
uh in a prior presentation and webinar
uh focused on the
uh toxicology findings associated with
this newer approach to drug screening
across our toxicology practice
in this session i'd like to focus on the
challenges
associated with with really making that
transition
and also uh give you some uh sense for
the some of the solutions we found along
the way in terms of uh addressing the
issues of um of conversion
this next slide shows the both the
outline of the presentation as well as
the listing of the
challenges that we did face
of the
selection of panels the technical issues
the informatic issues and also i would
like to address as part of this
agenda the impact on workflow as well as
economics
so let's start with the panel selection
i'm often asked what uh what you may
include when you are doing definitive uh
screening and really uh from a
toxicology standpoint that would be the
agents that are uh in our
in our our streets
and being used
in therapeutics and other agents they
may be misused
one of the advantages we have for mass
spectrometry is the ability to acquire
data across
many different analytes simultaneously
or with the rapid
electronics associated with ms the
ability to uh acquire data for
multi-analytes
and this is a listing of a panel of
analytes that we acquire uh in one of
our main panels
that is always being acquired for all of
the analytes
and then the
selection of a panel that may be an
agency's request for specific
drugs or agents
can be accomplished by processing only
the data associated with the ordered
drug tests
the next panel shows
us a panel that we use very early on
which in some ways mimics the uh class
of drugs that are be were being tested
by the uh presumptive
panels
and included agents that were in those
particular drug classes and we used that
for a conversion of a number of agencies
but quickly found that again from a
toxicology standpoint we really need to
go well beyond this uh and as
demonstrated in the first webinar that
we are missing a significant number of
agents uh because the scope of this
testing is limited
we use uh heavily a drug abuse panel
that continues to evolve this is a
70 analyte version of that of that panel
that includes not only the
classes of drugs that were covered by
presumptive testing but a more expanded
class of drugs based upon the needs and
the drugs that are being used and need
to be identified
in addition
we have addressed a number of agents
that are in our in the psychiatric
practice that are uh also out and in use
and uh may not be complied with and in
those particular cases we've added uh
antipsychotics antidepressants then this
would be considered a comprehensive
panel so i should note at this point
that the panels that each laboratory
selects will be tailored
to the needs of the
various agencies that uh they're serving
and uh will be uh updated as the newer
agents and designer agents continue to
evolve in your region of the country uh
and in your uh practice area so the the
selection is such that we want to have
acquisition of all the data uh for
example we're now adding siloson uh to
that because we've had a significant
number of cases of mushroom uh
utilization and misutilization
for hallucinogenic activity
and we do that by
updating this panel over
time there are technical issues also
associated with the transition to
definitive drug screening
and i'm going to address two of them uh
related to sample prep and related to
the analysis
by ms
automation is a key to this
we
have automated our preparation of
samples they're just too many samples
in the initial testing process for us to
actually handle
in a manual basis it's doable but it is
really not practical
this is an example of about 100 or so
specimens as well as calibrators
controls
and blind samples that are probably in
those those particular case samples and
they're being uh
a liquid handler is being used for the
preparation of those samples we use
exclusively 96 well plate
approach and do the preparation 96 well
plate the analysis and ms and 9612 plate
uh
format and this is uh up in the upper
left hand corner a 20 microliter sample
being kicked up from each of the cases
as well as the controls and calibrators
and being and the
the next
right hand side
shows the plates the 96 volt plates
where their delivery of the samples and
then the delivery of the
reagents
that are that are needed for that
particular testing and also uh
other agents that
delusions and other reagents that are
used are in a larger volume and
available for that
rapid addition process
down below on the right hand side
lower right hand side you can see that a
plate is being transferred
from the
initial preparation area and brought
over robotically to a mixing and
incubation area so it has temperature
control it has the ability for uh
mixing of the uh the components of that
particular reaction mixture
and it then is uh brought back over for
the final dilution
uh after that
hydrolysis and incubation and then
finally brought back for a mixing all in
automated sets a single plate is about
30 minutes for the preparation of the
plate and then depending upon your
hydrolysis time it will sit for
hydrolysis and then after that is
automatically diluted and then available
for analysis so we'll we'll pick the
first plate off uh after it is uh fully
prepared while a
second plate is being uh processed at
the same time and start our ms analysis
so in the center is the
uh
the iclass
acuity uh auto uh sampling system for
the uplc and the use of that 96 well
plate positioned within there so
automation is a key uh to the uh use of
ms in the
high volume
setting
some of the advantages associated with
it are the uh elimination of manual
additions
and to the extent that there are close
to 300 additions that are needed for a
single plate this becomes a very
both laborious process as well as one
that requires significant concentration
and is potentially error-prone in terms
of manual additions
whereas in the uh liquid handler it is
a script that is written that
robotically does that those same
additions each time can barcode identify
uh samples can barcode identify plates
and allows you as well as other reagents
and allows you to have a much better
control over the uh the preparation of
multi uh samples
the liquid handler script is uh
is prepped and in our case is prepared
for multiple plate uh preparation um
there is a
there is a
there is a
plate in which the hydrolysis
a
a plate submitted for uh preparation the
first place can be done in uh civilian
time so about an hour and a half into it
we are actually doing our ms uh analysis
the hydrolysis and the steps involved in
the additions are on the lower left hand
uh side and in that particular uh right
hand side i've uh presented again the
very important aspect of i uh graduation
the glucuronidase hydrolysis in that a
significant number of analytes would be
missed
because of low sensitivity uh because
they are in a group your audited uh form
so it's important that we actually go
through that uh that hydrolysis process
the second part of
the
the analysis that's important to address
in terms of high volume use is the
chromatographic analysis itself and we
have developed on a
high theoretical plate uh process using
uplc the ability to to have a
chromatographic separation in three
minutes
using dual transition acquisition of
data during that time frame we've
focused heavily on diastereo isomers
like his pseudoephedrine and ephedrine
separation and have also focused on
isobarics in terms of making sure that
we have good
chromatographic uh identity
for that but it's really this rapid uh
separation that's important again in
terms of processing that number of
samples
now
the use of this once developed and we
developed this for urine testing program
uh has also now been adapted to our oral
fluid uh drug screening program for
definitive or uh testing and screening
uh initial oral fluid samples and this
shows the uh format for that a little
bit different in terms of the addition
we add some more the sample volume uh is
uh is is twice the amount as in the
urine sample the obviously the
collection we use a passive drool uh a
buffered oral fluid that was developed
at ntc uh for that process and uh and
the collection
uh aid that is uh is available uh and
fda cleared for uh collection of oral
fluid and so we've adapted this
same approach to the use in oral fluid
not only are the automated
preparation sample
the analysis uh and and uh
the
uh by ms uh important but also is how we
do the analysis and the accuracy of that
analysis i'd like to spend a couple of
minutes on matrix effect and
quantitation
quantitation in the initial testing
process which is not normally
done but is easily handled in this
particular approach
this is a look at
the addition of 100 nanogram per ml
concentration of mda
to 42
negative urine analyte negative urine
samples and looking directly at the ion
areas that are
achieved
with each of those samples and you can
see the wide range of
ion area
associated with an approximate 2000
range up to uh
13 000
in terms of ion area and that variation
is essentially matrix effect that is
that the
competition at the source
for mda ionization will vary from sample
to sample depending upon other things
that are also in the source
this is an example of the suppression
ion suppression associated with
amphetamine by another drug
this is a
sample that was initially this is our a
panel of analytes
which were initially analyzed and
achieved a
baseline
ion response ion area and then following
that there was the addition of more and
more gabapentin
to this particular sample and then the
re-analysis at higher and higher levels
of gabapentin gabapentin coalutes
closely uh has a retention time 1.31 as
does amphetamine and in that
process is in the source at the same
time as you have more gabapentin it is
suppressing the ionization and the the
counts associated with amphetamine that
is a matrix effect caused by a co
analyte
in that particular sample
so look at it in terms of the
an image that kind of
tries to explain the uh what is
occurring if you look on the left hand
side you have a column in which you have
in this case
let's say a simulated sample which is
matrix-free
it is in your
starting mobile phase for example as a
sample and it contains amphetamine
when that particular sample gets to the
uh
the electrospray
uh
process and the ionization process at
high voltage uh in positive mode it
produces positive ions of amphetamine
and there are a certain number of ions
that are produced they're not the entire
number of molecules that are actually
presented to it but a significant or a
portion of them are actually ionized and
therefore taken up by
in this positive mode by the ms source
if you add to this
matrix
another
ionizable
ion in this case you have a pentane and
have that also along with amphetamine
you can see uh at least a depiction of
the fact that in this urine sample that
now has sediment in it compared to a a
matrix-free sample that because of this
competitiveness you're having ionization
of devopentine as well as amphetamine
and then that result is less amphetamine
ionization is occurring and that is why
the ion response in that particular
urine sample is different from the ion
response in the matrix free sample the
same is true from urine to urine
depending upon what is actually
coeluting and at the source uh result in
that kind of mda
effect that i showed before in those 42
urine samples
is therefore essential i believe in
either
qualitative work in terms of a threshold
using a threshold
quantitative work that we have a way of
normalizing the matrix set and the
primary
technique for that normalization is
standard isotope internal uh standard
stable isotope internal standardization
uh and
that has been used for a very long time
and uh and is is widely used for
quantitative work and confirmatory work
for ms analysis an alternate that we use
in our laboratory that i pointed to in
the last session is a threshold accurate
calibration a technique that is
essentially like a single point standard
edition although it is different because
it is in fact is
calibrated externally calibrated by uh
the calibrants that are used in the uh
process um i don't have time to go into
it but standard edition really would not
work for a system in which the analyte
itself
could be competing as you put more and
more analyte in so standard is this
typical standard edition that we used in
uh in toxicology for a long time does
not work very effectively
in
ms analysis
but this technique
uh is one approach so the first is to
have
stable
isotope standards
and we are fortunate that there are
availability of stabilized soaps for
many of the agents often when a new
designer agent comes in into use we are
awaiting those internal standards for
quantitative work uh but this is an
example of what i call analyte matched
stable isotope standards each one of
those analytes has a uh
duty a deuterated uh
standard associated with with it or a
c13
uh stable isotope uh
analog that is used because it will be
in the source at the same time and
therefore it undergoes the same uh level
of enhancement or suppression that may
occur for that particular analyte in
that sample at that moment in time
the approach that we've taken is was
initially recorded by us in 2016
as a
as a novel calibration uh technique
and just plain to it as an alternate
available method for this kind of matrix
normalization where we have a sample
that has in it an analyte and we
take a aliquot of that and we add to it
and spike it with a reference analyte
and you can see that you can have
therefore the initial analysis which is
just the analyte and then the spiked
analysis which includes both in which
you can do a quick subtraction of the
two to come up with really the
the amount of analyte endogenous and the
amount of added uh response for that
particular sample we call the attack
ratio
for that particular analysis
and you can see that as you take
analyte matrix iii or
two different
samples that may have different matrices
that the amount of suppression that may
occur for amphetamine for example is
shown by the ion the unique ion response
reaches them and you can see that they
are quite different and it would be not
be possible to calibrate uh unless you
use the exact matrix for that particular
sample but by adding this this
this addition and spiking process using
this threshold accurate calibration you
actually get a ratioing process that
normalizes so that you can calibrate uh
with a
with a
matrix such as a single urine negative
urine analyte negative urine that you're
using and can calibrate for all your
samples and be accurate across the
entire range of of samples that you're
analyzing at that particular run
we've also looked at this carefully in
terms of the
quantitative comparability to the stable
isotope method and this shows a
correlation that we've reported recently
in a publication that is in the special
issue of jack
for this year and uh is a comparison of
various techniques and in this papers
and also a very important point that
i'll make in right now is that i've
pointed out that you would use analyte
match stable isotopes
many of us have not in the past used
analyte matched stable isotopes where
we've shared a an isotope from an
analog
from another drug for example and i'll
show you the issues associated with this
and it was reported uh the head-to-head
comparison was reported in this paper
and this is use of uh hydrocodone d6
along with for the measurement of
hydrocodone for its identification and
quantitation and this is five two three
seven different matrices different urine
samples in which we have uh
have been analyzing that and you can see
that the response is very parallel in
terms of any matrix effect that may
occur in each of these uh samples
because again they're both in the source
at the same time experiencing the same
type of
effects in terms of competition for
ionization however if you look below and
you try to use dihydrocodeine or codeine
or some other
analytes internal standard to measure
hydrocodone there will be samples in
which there is a mismatch in that the in
this particular case the internal
standard has been suppressed
because it's moving through that source
with a different set of ions
and is uh is not at the
retained at the same time as the analyte
hydrocodone and it has a different
effect in terms of ion response and the
net effect is when you add
a
a certain level of drug and try to
recover it you recover very well that
particular drug i think it was at 230 or
235 nanograms of 235 nanograms per ml
concentration you find that when you
have this kind of circumstance in which
you have a non-matched deuterated
internal standard you can have quite
significant differences in the
concentration this won't be evident from
your quality control and calibration
which was done in a single matrix and uh
that was pointed out also in that in
that report so there are two methods but
we should be very careful about uh
analyte matched
stable isotope utilization
i'd like to move on now to the
management of the data because it is
one of the largest challenges associated
with
the
use of definitive methods in the initial
screening process and i point that out
by showing you the data volume that we
are confronted with
when we have these kinds of analysis of
100 to 200 samples we have
800
transitions
per case
and we have 100 to 200 cases
so we have thousands and thousands of
transition iron counts that we are
managing that data and doing the
processing of results in addition we
have uh we have to because we are doing
a quantitative mode we have calibration
curves 100 calibration curves and uh in
the range of 500 quality control uh per
run there is there is not it is not
possible to use some of the you know the
basic methods in terms of of
quantitation and calibration curves when
you're doing this many calibration
curves
at the volume that we're using in this
particular case
so what is our approach to it
our approach is a data analysis and this
this is really another challenge for the
industry itself is to be able to manage
the data but this is a we ourselves
export the data
the msms
data and
put it into a template that already has
all of the calculations all the
algorithms all the criteria and all the
analysis rules so that we can actually
perform those uh
those analyses are performed and
automated sense by just putting that
exported data into the template
and it shows up as i'll show you in a
moment all of our calibration curves
and it allows us also to review by
exception
for looking at anything that doesn't
meet our rules or criteria and have a
much better managed approach to a a
volume of data that is is quite
significant in uh
directed definitive testing
the calibrators and controls we find are
best to look at from an analyte
standpoint so i'll show you that
analysis and how the uh the analysts and
the certifying scientists look at that
data and the case work data is best to
look at in terms of across all the
analytes for that particular sample
so let me just give you the uh the
outputted calculations that are
performed in this for a calibration
curve this is a nor fentanyl calibration
curve uh showing the calibrators and and
qc uh samples showing the
attack in this case it was done by a
attack technique so with attack ratio
calculation for each of those samples
in this case since it is tac we have a
we make sure that the recovery between
the two injections is an acceptable uh
criteria so we have criteria around the
recovery uh
in which we put methapiroline into both
samples and then check for the
the accuracy of the five microliter
volume injection into the mass
spectrometer we also have criteria for
the the quantitative uh
recovery in terms of plus or minus 20
for calibrators and for qc material the
iron ratio criteria that is used in
confirmatory method we use in the
initial testing method the rt criteria
in terms of of the the peak that is
found as well as this injection criteria
or recovery
we also look at carry over and display
that and show you limits of quantitation
the lower limits of quantitation upper
limit as well as lod so sitting in front
of the analyst for a look at quality
control is all the essentials and we
have them light up uh we have an
exception criteria well there they will
not only say
fail but they will also light up so you
can very quickly
see what problems you may be having with
an analyte down below is the actual
regression
analysis for the uh
for the uh the standard curve and a
visualization of the standard curve and
an r square for that particular standard
curve
when it comes to the cases once we are
through our quality control for the 100
plus analytes and we quality control all
the analytes and therefore are ready to
do any panels that are necessary
for that particular uh run we then uh
look at our case work and our case work
also is driven by criteria of it where
we have the analyte
we have the uh the rt for the calibrator
the uh
the uh the rt for the analyte is then
checked against that the case uh attack
ratio the calibrator attack ratio for
the
one of the calibrators so we can get
ourselves in range on that as well as
the the information of what the cutoff
is for that particular sample the lower
limit of quantitation for the sample
then we have criteria for the rt if we
do find
uh a
peak for that particular uh sample we
look at the uh ion ratio
for that and it also has a criteria and
we also have an injection criteria
that's used and we also have a
calculation that is done off of that
calibration curve that i showed you
before to give a uh quantitation for
that uh that sample
and the end result is if we do find a
sample that meets all those criteria it
will actually show up as a finding so
this is uh buprenorphine nor
buprenorphine there's also benzoligonine
found in the case a gabapentin naloxone
which was part of the buprenorphine
therapy
oxymorphone which is really uh
nor naloxone uh it is the identical and
structure to it and uh came from the
naloxone metabolism uh this is an
individual that uh
that was on amitriptyline you can see
the amitriptyline level the
nortriptyline level and they were also
on tracidone and the tracidor metabolite
and they were also on a sedative using a
sedative agent and they're smokers so we
also have cottony
so there's a lot of information that
comes from that particular
testament
so in in the last area is to look at
impact and
the impact on both our workflow as well
as the economics
and to summarize the workflow uh is
is on this slide uh indicating that a
single analytical platform is now used
uh we're not moving between immunoassay
and the
mass spec between screen and confirm
we're on the mass spec for these agents
on both the screening and the confirm
the automated sample preparation saves
us significant time
and gives us much greater quality
assurance and reliability in the
preparation of those
those samples at high volume
the ability for us to have a selected
identification of drugs and
tablets is now seen in that screening
process you just saw the results of an
initial testing and the extent of
findings that are associated with that
but it allows a definitive level of of
not only screening for positives but
also screening for negatives so all the
negatives are also being done and and
resulted uh the definitive
method and again increases the insert of
the certainty associated with those
results
the batch analysis allows testing for up
to 150 samples per run
the samples and the
the calibrators and the controls are
analyzed prepped analyzed in within
about a four hour period and then the
samples are coming off and
as each chromatographic uh
each of them are
analyzed
in that
ms process
and we since we do such a significant
number of samples we will set them up
and then overnight have all that
analysis done so that we can then
analyze the samples
the next day and
provide reporting
i haven't put a copy of our report but i
think it's important to know that just
sending out the results of each of those
samples uh each of those tests that i
showed you
may not be sufficient there's there's
good information
uh from brigands and women's
hospital that looked at this that found
out that there's just too much
information that might be uh put out and
various uh
forensic agencies uh have uh you know
just are not able to digest and really
understand all the information is put
out so we put out interpretive reports
that has key findings in terms of the
drug finding and how that's associated
with the test
themselves and also allows interpretive
information to be provided along with
those
reports
and finally the economics uh we uh
we recognize and and know that that the
cost uh associated with the equipment uh
is higher uh on the ms uh
side for definitive uh testing and the
that initial investment is higher than
uh than tabletop and you know assay uh
systems uh that are out there and
therefore the
the direct uh cost
of
having that built into a direct cost
will affect the
the relative cost of a sample in terms
of the testing and
it is not until you actually have
increased volume of testing that you
ultimately have less cost associated
with definitive testing and that's
because the variable cost associated
with the two approaches is quite
different
between the reagent cost for presumptive
testing and the
ongoing cost per sample of definitive
testing and we find somewhere in the
range of 10 to 50 000
cases which is about uh 200 samples per
week or so is is close to where we uh
actually
um have a uh a net savings from
the
use of the
testing
so in summary
uh
liquid handler coupled with uh with a
simplified sample prep
rapid chromatographic ms analysis allows
the high volume throughput and solves uh
those analytical aspects and workflow
aspects in terms of testing matrix
normalization is essential
part of good practice in terms of
having that
using
either
analyte match stable isotopes or other
alternative approaches
definitive screening data for calibrated
controls in case is manageable uh
casework is manageable by a rules-based
criteria base and review by exception
and when you get into this kind of
volume that is the approach that that is
needed
for handling that volume and the cost
effectiveness is really case volume
dependent uh in terms of direct indirect
cost therefore
so
i answer to the question i posed this
question as the
topic for this uh webinar is can
definitive drug screenings uh become
routine and our experience uh is that
the answer is yes
and it does take a significant amount of
solutions to uh challenges that i showed
in this uh in this webinar and i'd be
happy to discuss uh those or answer any
questions associated with uh our
approach to it and uh
look forward to those uh discussions so
thank you very much for your attention
and thank you very much dr asano for
that informative presentation we will
now start the live q a portion of the
webinar and if you have any questions
you want to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
so dr rosano looks like we already have
some great questions coming in from our
audience
regarding your test panels how do you
validate and added new drugs to the
panels
uh we're always in the process of of
adding and validating um new analytes
and additions to the panel and the way
we do that is
after optimizing the conditions for each
of those analytes in terms of of optimum
changes of cone voltage collision energy
uh retention time we put that
information into the acquisition program
so we're actually acquiring the data for
those particular uh
analytes while we're doing our runs
and we uh we therefore have them in our
calibrator so we're calibrating so we're
getting all of our our calibration curve
data we're getting all of our quality
control data uh during those runs we're
not processing any any case samples
with it but we are getting all of that
uh that data so a great deal of the
validation is actually performed during
routine testing and uh as i said the
number of agents we're currently working
on now are being handled in just that
way they are being acquired
they are uh processed for quality
control data and allowing us to validate
those particular uh analyses um
prior to
use in practice
thank you so much now did you include
blind samples in your testing program
yes part of the protocol for
forensic laboratory and good protocol
for for other laboratories is the use of
challenging us with a blind sample
program one of the things that we we
learned in this was because we added so
many analytes that we wanted to make
sure that we tested all analytes so we
have an interesting approach to the
blind program where the certifying
scientist
is is submitting uh samples blind to the
analysts
in which they uh include what would be
considered to be reasonable
relationships between drugs metabolites
and various therapies that that
might be
used or misused drugs that might be
misused and those
uh are then submitted along with the
case work so they're somewhere in that
case work
and the certifying scientists will then
evaluate that
as to whether that is an acceptable run
so every run has it and we run through
uh as i said there's over 100 analytes
we make sure that we uh
test
through this blind program all analytes
regularly so we kind of rhythmically go
through all the analytes and they put us
about a 14 or 15 different combination
group
that we send to us blind samples so yes
we do use the blind sample program very
important process
thank you so much dr rosano and i want
to thank our audience for these great
questions coming in
dr rasano what level of technical staff
do you need in a direct to definitive
drug testing protocol
uh well in in our setting we need a
licensed uh analyst uh technologist uh
to perform that and they um they need to
be trained in ms analysis
and in the techniques and the uh
approaches that we're taking our
laboratory to ensure the quality and
effectiveness of those uh testing
process so it is uh not unlike other
areas of specialty testing
not unlike postmortem toxicology where
uh the training of an individual they
may come with a significant amount of
education some experience but the actual
training is really
on the job training that occurs so we do
need good qualified
analysts
for that testing
process and we also need certifying
scientists uh to review the data that
comes from that and they are essentially
analysts with a
the greatest amount of experience in our
laboratory that are serving in that
particular role as well as the
toxicologists
thank you so much for our next question
an audience an audience member wants to
know
is your final report just a listing of
screen and confirmed test results or do
you provide summary and interpretive
information as well
well you know i thought of that during
the session i think i made a comment on
it that i didn't show you an example of
the report but the report is starts off
with key findings
we do uh identify each of the each of
the tests that are positive but we put
it into a context
uh so initially and the context
initially is a summary context that is
is drug oriented drug use oriented so
that we can be talking about uh the
uh the drugs and metabolites and other
findings that may be associated with
that particular
drug use
so there's a key finding section there
is a initial test section which is that
screening process and there is also
confirmatory testing uh reported along
with quantitation but if you look up in
the top you'll find interpretive
information along with key findings that
help to identify that we never just list
or alphabetize the the tests or the test
results we think that that really does
not
add to it you know having a hundred uh
agents just listed in terms of positive
or negative uh really is not uh serving
the interest
of
drug courts
probation departments and others who are
receiving uh are having testing
performed
for them
thank you so much we have time for one
more question dr rosano do you have
experience with using a limited number
of stable isotopes for screening a large
panel of drug and metabolic metabolite
uh tests
i think all of us in toxicology have
over time really used that uh particular
approach and
the experience divest is a study
experience where we actually um
it's recently it's reported in java as i
pointed to in the presentation
in which we actually took a look at uh
using shared internal standards versus
using analyte match internal standards
and we found both of the issues of
recovery
when we use multiple matrices and we
also showed the issue of dispersion
of the quantitative relationship between
the
the analyte matched approach
and the shared
internal standard approach
tac and the analyte match are agreeing
very well in some cases quite discrepant
when the shared
internal standard was in use so we're
just adding a caution that
depending upon matrix effect you may not
and and the fact that your calibrators
and controls may be prepared in a single
matrix that you are really not assessing
effectively whether there may be a
matrix effect in your individual sample
and
so that that approach um
it isn't used but has to be used with a
great deal of caution
based upon reliability of of accuracy
dr asana thank you so much for your
presentation today would you like to
provide any final comments to our
audience before we go
yes i think this uh two webinar series
was a good session for me also to kind
of put in perspective
a significant number of years of
working through the issues and finally
coming to a point in which we have it in
routine practice and can show the value
the
the value in terms of the
information that is provided
in a drug testing
program
and also
hopefully advance the practice of drug
testing so that it serves our
our agencies and others in a very
effective uh manner so it's uh it was
helpful in the first session to look at
the results of our finding and i think
even for myself it's helpful to look at
and kind of analyze
all the things that we had to do to try
to to get there and each laboratory will
do it differently with a different
approach
and it's really the sharing of
experience between laboratories that's
probably most valuable so i i enjoyed it
and
and hopefully it has some benefit to
others and other practitioners
well we want to thank you again dr asana
for your time and for your important
research and i also want to take the
time to thank labrus and our sponsor
waters corporation for underwriting
today's educational webcast and before
we go i want to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted on the on-demand period will
be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information we provided at the
time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
libraries will
email you and alert you when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time everyone take care be
safe
bye